[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
freitagabend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert könig für den sport
genommen wir haben unter anderem diese
themen für sie
hoffen und bangen reichen die härteren
corona maßnahmen aus um die
infektionszahlen zu drücken
skifahren im lockdown österreichs
wintersport tourismus setzt erst mal nur
auf tagesgäste
[Applaus]
trauer um horst ecke den letzten wm
helden von 54
die korona beschlüsse von bund und
ländern sollen das virus bremsen doch
etliche mediziner und biologen sind
skeptisch und halten weitere kontakt
beschränkungen für nötig der präsident
des robert koch-instituts wieder fordert
die neuen maßnahmen schnell umzusetzen
erste effekte gebe es frühestens in etwa
zwei wochen die fallzahlen seien nach
wie vor viel zu hoch aktuell meldet das
rk ii 74
1352 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
das sind etwa 2000 weniger als vor einer
woche 390 weitere todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sieben tage incident steigt leicht
auf 4
142,1 vermutlich gibt es aber deutlich
mehr infizierte sagt der lka chef
derzeit könnten viele fälle nicht mehr
erfasst werden andreas huppert berichtet
wuppertal nordrhein westfalen gestern
nacht das ordnungsamt auf streife
flächendeckend gilt hier in der
gastronomie zweig genießen oder geimpft
alle anderen müssen draußen bleiben wir
haben jetzt bislang insgesamt acht
verstöße wobei man dazusagen muss dass
gegen die jeweiligen betreiber natürlich
auch ein ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren
eröffnet wird weil die ihre
aufsichtspflicht sozusagen nicht
nachgekommen sind konsequente kontrolle
der gestern beschlossenen corona
maßnahmen in allen bundesländern das
soll die pandemie eindämmen der
ärztepräsident fordert allerdings
zusätzlich bundesweit zweig plus also
tester für genesene und geimpfte zum
beispiel in clubs und bars zusätzlich
oder in kleinen restaurant zusammensitzt
und ich finde dass mal ein fußballspiel
und großveranstaltungen für gewissen
zeitraum hätte ganz aussetzen können
auch jens spahn wird nicht müde zu
warnen denn nicht nur die
intensivstationen sind überlastet
sondern auch die labore die die pcr
tests auswerten stoßen an ihre
kapazitätsgrenzen problem dabei
infizierte werden das verspätet
informiert dies wiederum erhöht das
ansteckungsrisiko
wir haben jetzt wieder so viel pcr tests
in jeder woche wie auch sonst in den
höchst phasen der pandemie mit
gleichzeitig einem sehr sehr hohen
positiv anteil also der in hoher zahl
der testung in den tcr labor ist positiv
so hoch wie selten in den letzten 18
monaten und das deutet darauf hin dass
es eine unter erfassung gibt diese unter
erfassung also die zu spät gemeldeten
infektionen kommen zu einer zeit in der
auch noch die neue virusvariante omikron
auftritt klar ist dass omikron in
deutschland angekommen ist und nach
allem was wir mit stand heute wissen
könnte micon auch noch ansteckender sein
und auch geimpfte und genesene leichter
infizieren die 31 pk zur coroner lage
war jeden spaß letzte als
gesundheitsminister wer die nachfolge
antritt ist unklar sicher dagegen die
korona pandemie sie bleibt
fragen wir theo koll in berlin jens
spahn geht aber ein neuer
gesundheitsminister beziehungsweise
ministerin ist noch nicht benannt und
das in dieser schweren krise wie kann
das sein ja das waren sich aktuell
selbst hochrangige vertreter der anderen
parteien wenn man in der spd nachfragt
ob olaf scholz sich mehr zeit nimmt als
er gefühlt hat dann fällt das leicht
genervte stichwort mediendebatte erst
müsste doch morgen der parteitag über
den koalitionsvertrag entscheiden und
die künftigen kabinettsmitglieder seien
überhaupt erst ab mittwoch im amt die
ganze debatte dreht sich vor allem um
karl lauterbach der obwohl ja experte
nicht als gesetzt gilt dahinter steht
nicht zuletzt die frage der
geschlechtergleichheit scholz hat
parität im kabinett versprochen nun hat
die fdp aber drei männer und nur eine
frau nominiert das heißt scholz muss das
ausgleichen und damit wird es sehr eng
für spd männer am sonntagabend
jedenfalls sollen bei den ausgewählten
dann die scholz anrufe eingehen
dankeschön nach berlin theo koll
gestern haben bund und länder
zusätzliche chor ohne regeln als
einheitliche mindeststandards
beschlossen einige schärfen schon nach
baden württemberg begrenzt
großveranstaltungen auf maximal 750
personen im restaurants gilt zweig plus
heißt testpflicht für geimpfte und
genesene die weitet auch rheinland pfalz
auf innenräume wo keine maske getragen
werden kann neben gastronomie etwa
fitnessstudios aber werden gepustet ist
muss hier keinen zusätzlichen test
machen diese regel führt auch
niedersachsen ein
deutschlandweit sind es vor allem die
ungeimpften für die massive
einschränkungen gelten
gesundheitsminister sparen hat das heute
noch mal so begründet wären alle
erwachsenen deutschen geimpft steckten
wir nicht in dieser schwierigen lage die
politik erhöht also deutlich den druck
was das bei bisher nicht geimpften
auslöst zeigt lisa huber wer hier ab
montag weihnachtsgeschenke einkaufen
will muss geimpft oder genesen sein am
schnell testzentrum daneben aber sind
einige die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen mein impfausweis ist voll mit
allen informieren wie es gibt
gegenmittel gegen borken gegen alles
möglichst jedes jahr aber
so was unter druck
das ist was anderes als eben von jobs
wurde so alles gleich und ich also mein
natürlich kann man jetzt den dadurch ins
kino gehen aber kann auch zu hause kino
gruppen manch einer hat dem druck aber
nachgegeben diese beiden sind seit
kurzem einmal geimpft weil sie um ihren
job fürchten weil wenn sie wirklich die
zweijährige durchführen
genauso sieht es aus wie sollen wir
sparen können andere haben sich
überzeugen lassen
durch meine oma hat nicht endlich im
verlassen weil sie das halt unbedingt
weiter und sie sind nicht allein zuletzt
hatte es in sachsen anhalt deutlich mehr
erstimpfungen gegeben bis zu 6.500 am
tag die verhaltens psychologin kathrin
schmelzer aber verweist auf mögliche
negative folgen des erhöhten drucks bei
dem anderen teil der ungeimpften wird es
den frust erhöhen und er zu einer
trotzreaktion führen so zu dem gefühl
jetzt erst recht nicht um dem
entgegenzuwirken sei weitere begleitende
aufklärung über die impfung wichtig
die bundesregierung stuft polen und die
schweiz als hochrisiko gebiet ein heißt
ungeimpfte die von dort nach deutschland
einreisen müssen für zehn tage in
quarantäne drei anderen nachbarländer
gelten bereits als hochrisiko gebiete
die niederlande belgien und österreich
im österreichischen ischgl startete
heute bei prächtigem wetter die
skisaison nach fast zwei jahren
stillstand laufen die lifte wieder
allerdings gilt in den bergbahnen zweig
und masken pflicht hotels und
restaurants sind wegen des landesweiten
lockt downs geschlossen britta hilpert
über einen besonderen saisonstart
idealbedingungen in ischgl und kaum
skifahrer saisonstart mit 20 prozent der
üblichen gäste der lockte erlaubt
skifahren zur physischen erholung so die
regelung und in den gondeln herrscht
zweig und masken pflicht den ruf als
super spacer ort wie die apres ski
hochburg endlich loswerden der lock down
erlaubt keine gastronomie die touristen
kommen trotzdem sogar aus deutschland
morgens hin abends zurück und ich ziehe
immer wieder auch ohne après ski es hat
einfach die lust am snowboard fahren und
dann steigen wir uns ins auto morgens um
vier und hat dann hat uns viel gebiet
der lust am skifahren steht die not in
krankenhäusern gegenüber aus überfüllten
kliniken in salzburg werden patienten
nach wien verlegt noch steigen die
krankenhauseinweisungen aber die
infektionszahlen gehen zurück besonders
seit der lock down auf alle ausgeweitet
wurde in ischgl hoffen sie auf ein ende
des lockouts noch vor weihnachten
zahllose hotels und restaurants sind gut
gebucht das kids noch galt pandemie
beginn als virenschleuder nun sei man
hier sehr sicherheitsbewusst mal wird
bernard fange ob und wie après ski
laufen könnte ist unklar die gäste
werden so oder so kommen meint er wenn
sie dürfen schauen auf eine gute saison
voraus nur ich halt immer die
unsicherheit zu groß leider weil wir
nicht wissen wie können wir auf spenden
13 können wir überhaupt aufsperren
nächste woche erst wird entschieden ob
der lotto am 13 dezember endet
das wort des jahres ja das war
naheliegend hat auch mit corona zu tun
wellenbrecher hat die jury der
gesellschaft für deutsche sprache gekürt
wellenbrecher dienen ja eigentlich dem
küstenschutz aktuell wird der begriff
aber auch genutzt um strategien zu
beschreiben die die vierte welle brechen
so ein
ganz anderes thema aufklärung und
konsequenzen vor allem das fordern die
angehörigen der opfer von hanau auch
rund 22 monate nach dem anschlag am 19
februar 2020 tötete ein 43-jähriger
deutscher neun menschen aus
rassistischen motiven für die
hinterbliebenen sind bis heute viele
fragen offen sie hoffen dass ein
untersuchungsausschuss mögliche
versäumnisse von polizei und behörden
erklärt susanne santina
angehörige aller opfer des rassistischen
anschlag sind nach wiesbaden gekommen
für den untersuchungsausschuss hatten
sie lange gekämpft und anzeigen unter
anderem gegen die hanauer polizei
erstattet die staatsanwaltschaft hatte
die ermittlungen aber eingestellt viele
fragen bleiben für sie offen nicht nur
juristische auch politische
was haben wir da noch in der hand alles
wird auf zeit
damit bisschen gras drüber wächst um
dann eingestimmt und jetzt vielleicht
hoffen mehr wenn wir alle zusammen
weiter druck machen vielleicht kriegen
wir endlich mit genosse aufklärung zum
auftakt wurden heute die angehörigen von
fahrschule und kalorien weil kopf gehört
sie beklagten unter anderem die lange
zeit fehlende psychologische betreuung
und dass sie über die ermittlungen vor
allem durch die medien erfahren hätten
außerdem wird es im u-ausschuss darum
gehen warum war der notruf für millipore
nicht erreichbar er hatte den täter mit
seinem auto verfolgt und dreimal
erfolglos versucht die polizei zu
erreichen will dies vater stellt fragen
denn der notruf war unterbesetzt und das
system veraltet ich brauche eine antwort
weil die die zentrale die notruf hat
wie gesagt mehr den 20 schade probieren
ein weiterer offener punkt warum bei der
notausgang im zweiten tatort versperrt
was wohl für zeitmesser chemie und hansa
coach zur todesfalle wurde und dass der
notausgang abgeschlossen ist und alle
sagen auf anordnung der polizei und dass
die polizei ist wusste auch dazu hatte
die staatsanwaltschaft die ermittlungen
eingestellt im u ausschuss will man für
klarheit sorgen weil die angehörigen ein
recht darauf haben möglichst viel zu
wissen was passiert ist und alles was
irgendwie möglich ist aufzuklären das
müssen wir hier leisten aufklärung
gerechtigkeit und konsequenzen das
erhoffen sich alle angehörigen
jetzt zu einer chinesischen bloggerin
deren schicksal derzeit nicht nur
tausende im internet bewegt als corona
in rohan ausbrach da filmte die juristin
chan chan das chaos und die verzweiflung
und stellte ihre videos ins netz sie kam
dafür ins gefängnis und trat aus protest
in einen hungerstreik jetzt bank ihre
familie um ihr aus peking stephanie
schöneborn
jancan die video bloggerin wurde zu vier
jahren gefängnis verurteilt weil sie
hinschaute ihre videos werfen den
behörden in johann vor die menschen
nicht früh genug informiert zu haben
fragen wo das virus herkommt für die
kommunistische partei ist das gefährlich
der sie den ruhmreichen kampf der partei
gegen das virus in frage stellt also
wird sie verhaftet
eine kommunistische partei will das
gesicht wahren sie wollen der welt diese
waren dinge nicht zeigen doch hat genau
das gemacht
damit hat sie die rote linie der
kommunistischen partei überschritten
also haben sie sie eingesperrt
dieses und viele andere videos werden im
netz verbreitet sowie die aufforderung
sondern freizulassen sie befindet sich
in einem hungerstreik um gegen ihre
verurteilung zu demonstrieren ihr wird
vorgeworfen mit ihren videos streit
geführt und unruhe gestiftet zu haben
sie nur noch 40 kilogramm circa ihre
familie ist extrem besorgt um sie sie
macht sich sorgen dass sie den winter
nicht überleben wird wenn sie nicht
sofort auf grund der wirklich
dramatischen medizinischen situation in
der sie sich befindet entlassen werden
in china verschwinden immer wieder
menschen wie st für die kommunistische
partei ist das eine innere angelegenheit
in die sich niemand einmischen darf
seit vier jahren sitzt der türkische
kultur mit zehn osman kavala in
gefängnis ohne gerichtsurteile erst zum
zweiten mal in seiner geschichte leitet
der europarat deshalb ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren
gegen einen mitgliedsstaat ein die
türkei heißt es zur begründung habe
kavala noch immer nicht freigelassen
obwohl das der europäische gerichtshof
für menschenrechte längst angeordnet
hatte
in österreich geht das politische
stühlerücken weiter der bisherige
innenminister karl hammer soll neuer
bundeskanzler werden und den vorsitz der
konservativen övp
nehmen beide posten waren gestern
überraschend frei geworden erst hatte vp
chef kurz seinen rückzug aus der politik
erklärt am abend war dann auch kanzler
schallenberg zurückgetreten wir blicken
auf deutschlands wichtigstem
wirtschaftszweig die autoindustrie auch
sie leidet und deutlich unter der
pandemie computerchips können nicht
geliefert werden es wird weniger
produziert und weniger verkauft im
november sind nur rund 200.000 autos neu
zugelassen worden
33 prozent weniger als im november vor
einem jahr umso begehrter sind
gebrauchtwagen lothar becker hat mehr
neuwagen sind derzeit knapp vor allem
kleinere und mittelklassemodelle und
egal welche marke selbst wer einen
neuwagen bestellt hat darf nicht damit
rechnen in auch rechtzeitig zu bekommen
jetzt muss man sich halt vorstellen dass
der kunde vor allem jahren schon wie es
dargestellt hat und jetzt ja jetzt
gebiete einfach nicht geliefert und den
tritt natürlich jetzt nach einem jahr
langsam mal vom vertrag zurück und die
gebrauchte alternative auf dem hof ist
nicht vorhanden gute gebrauchtwagen sind
selten und teuer händler suchen meist
bundesweit um ihren kunden attraktive
autos anbieten zu können nach
berechnungen des online-portals
autoscout24 liegt der durchschnittspreis
für gebrauchte derzeit gut 18 prozent
über dem vorjahresniveau
es gibt seit über 20 jahren immer den
gebrauchtwagenpreise niemals auf einen
wert von fast 25.000 euro
einhergehend aber auch mit noch nie eine
mehr so stark untergehenden angebot das
es eine menge bewegung im markt einfach
gerade was am ende bleibt ist die wenig
attraktive wahl zwischen eher teuren
gebrauchtwagen oder neuwagen ohne
individuelle extras da muss der kunde
vielleicht auch tatsächlich mehr
kompromisse machen als vorher und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr geld
ausgeben als vorher aber letztendlich
ist es schon so dass er sich nicht mehr
unter vielen fahrzeugen etwas
auswirkungen echte profiteure der
lieferengpässe sind die werkstätten
statt neue zu kaufen wird länger
gefahren und dadurch auch öfter
repariert
norbert und nun heißt es abschied nehmen
vom letzten fußball weltmeister von 1954
jahr so gerne hätte er im februar noch
seinen neunzigsten geburtstag gefeiert
heute ist horst eckel gestorben mit leib
und seele war dem ersten fc
kaiserslautern verbunden erst vergangene
woche wurde er in die hall of fame des
deutschen fußballs aufgenommen
er war der jüngste und mittendrin im
legendären wunder team von sepp
herberger der pfälzer kostete aber sein
abschlag bleibt bei eckl aus
kaiserslautern hängender zu seinem
klubkameraden fritz walter von dort zur
an
[Musik]
wenn man mit span span sich schon mal
weltmeister gehört das ist ein ganz ganz
tolle sache ecke spitzname windhund
wegen seiner schlaksigen schnelligkeit
absolvierte 32 länderspiele und wurde
zweimal deutscher meister mit dem ersten
fc kaiserslautern sportlich bis ins hohe
alter geehrt mit dem
bundesverdienstkreuz nun ist er 89
jährig gestorben die fußball welt
trauert
[Applaus]
so hätte morgen abend gewiss die
südtribüne im dortmunder stadion
ausgesehen dem anlass angemessen doch
aus den hinreichend bekannten gründen
werden nur maximal 15.000 menschen den
bundesliga-hit vor ort verfolgen dürfen
das top spiel borussia dortmund gegen
bayern münchen der rahmen wird er haben
den letzten herbst erinnern lückenhaft
besetzte ränge nur 15.000 fans schade
für diesen bundesliga-gipfel weiß dass
die 15.000 den dort man auch sehr laut
sein können vielleicht nicht so laut wie
760 aber trotzdem laut genug lauten
jubel gab es zuletzt oft nur einen punkt
rückstand auf den dauer-rivalen die
gelb-schwarzen könnten die
tabellenführung übernehmen treffen auf
einen rekordmeister der weiterhin auf
kimmig und eventuell goretzka verzichten
muss ich glaube schon auch das morgen
jetzt nicht zwingen die deutsche
meisterschaft entschieden wird aber es
ist natürlich ein spiel mit
signalwirkung dortmund baut auf den
kampfgeist eines erling holland die
statistik spricht jedoch für bayern die
letzten sechs duelle gewannen allesamt
die münchner
ja schauen wir auf die realität morgen
werden wir tun dankeschön norbert
vorsicht warnt katja hornuf ab heute
nacht wird es glatt mit schnee und regen
mehr dazu hat sie gleich christian
sievers begrüßt sie im regional um 10
und wir wünschen ihnen ein unbeschwertes
wochenende
alles gute und wir sind morgen wieder
hier auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend da kommt ein neues tieferen
und das bringt uns regen schnee und ganz
gefährlichen glatteisregen das nächste
tief hier von der nordsee bringt uns in
der nacht zu sonntag auch in
norddeutschland kräftige schneefälle
heute nacht fällt regen schneeregen und
schnee es kann überall sehr gefährlich
glatt sein denn fast überall sinken die
temperaturen auf plus 3 bis minus sieben
grad und einzig am niederrhein und auf
den ostfriesischen inseln ist es wohl
ganz knapp zu mild für glätte und morgen
über tag bleibt es kalt für die
allermeisten von uns mit
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 2 und 5 grad
anders sieht es im südwesten aus da wird
es sehr mild bei 6 bis 11 grad das ist
dem starken bis stürmischen südwestwind
geschult und so setzt im schwarzwald
auch tauwetter am gefährlichsten ist es
morgen früh hier in bayern wenn der
regen auf den noch gefrorenen boden
fällt wird es spiegelglatt auch schnee
fällt morgen vormittag bayerischen wald
im thüringer wald auch in sachsen berlin
und brandenburg das lästern am
nachmittag nach dafür schüttet es ganz
ergiebig im südwesten und auch am
zweiten advent am sonntag gibt es
weitere schnee regen und schneeschauer
bei nur noch 1 bis 5 grad guten abend